congratulations to you my friend look at
that white woman you're with God damn
[Applause]
[Applause]
that [ __ ] behind you going yeah son I'm
with my girl but yo for real that white
woman's amazing isn't she tell the truth
he's with his black girlfriend like no I
don't know but that she's high level
that's a high level white woman right
there that white women is that is man oh
man oh man black women get mad at that
but that is top shelf white woman right
there
foreign
[Applause]
how pretty a white woman is
the value you look at it and then you
wonder how long they would look for if
she was missing
come on take a look take a look look at
this [ __ ]
[Applause]
I saw you look mad sweetie how long have
you was missing how long you think they
were how long you think they were
exactly she don't even she went
you know the deal I ain't saying nothing
wrong white woman's life is valuable
what's his name you're in uh vandersloot
right
we found out he was a serial kill man he
kills women that's what he do he do it
well
you know what I mean we know the girl
that he that he you know supposedly had
uh what's girl in Aruba Natalie Holloway
right but the one he just killed the
girl in Peru what's her name um
exactly
[Applause]
look up as you said now you said Natalie
Natalie
that angel
I said that like Family Feud all right
name a white girl I've been missing for
five years
foreign
[Applause]
girl that was killed yesterday
[Applause]
what is that big head third world
Peruvian bitch's name
[Applause]
has to be yours so something Goofy
don't get mad at yourself I gave it to
you you saw how fast you said Natalie
Holloway
Diana Ross right here said man she knew
her name
that white guy with Natalie Holloway
man you caught yourself uh
God bless you man that is high level
right then don't be ashamed of it
gorgeous
she mad as hell [ __ ] that white [ __ ]
you know come on come on
ain't nobody looking for you I might
look for you but the news ain't you
think Fox is reporting you missing let's
be honest Nancy Grace she leads story on
Nancy Grace
for the next six months
oh look at that because she's mad as
hell black women don't like that [ __ ]
but it is what it is let's be
I'm gonna be like that let's just let's
be honest
that little girl that went missing um
she was sailing little girl I'm gonna
say I forgot her damn it but she was she
went sailing and went missing in the
Indian Ocean okay and they spent
good Lord her mask broke and she was
floating around and she gave her her
little signal her Beacon they look for
it they spent 500 000 like tax money to
search for her
now that's my daughter I want that to
happen too but
but
if you go sailing
let's be honest how long you think are
they gonna spend five come on remember
hey remember football players in Miami
went missing they went sailing they look
for them for eight minutes
maybe they just sent somebody at the
edge of the beach
I don't
I don't see him we have to call off the
search because it's too much sun uh the
Sun the conditions are abnormally
difficult
foreign
if I go sailing I'm taking a white baby
on a keychain with me
[Applause]
and my boat goes
go down me I'm gonna have it hooked
right to the side of my belt
and I'ma dress the baby real white too
I'm gonna uh put sweatpants on it and
a pair of Ugg boots and I'm gonna
take a picture and
look at this white baby you don't come
get me this white baby going down with
me
foreign
[Applause]
I hate how much fun black people can
have racially man it's just
I can say anything I goddamn want
racially and white people have to sit
there and take it yeah
I am evil yes he's like come on man
say it because of that I like I I love I
love a little
look look man you know
let's be fair I mean
honestly be nicer with the racial game I
mean it I like to talk to uh you know
white people about being honest about uh
Obama
you gave it a shot
you did
you gave it a two-year shot like oh yeah
I tried I tried to
we tried to
it's not it's just it fell apart it
really it really did and I'm gonna tell
you something you don't know about black
folks
we would be on your side
uh and talking to white people we would
be on your side a lot more if you would
uh you know just not ever talk about how
you feel about anything
Rachel we'll catch up to you now serious
cause black people on the edge of going
what the [ __ ] is Obama
people outwardly hated them so we can't
we go if you shut them you shut up
I'll be against them like stop
I'm in rallies and all kinds of stuff
I'm telling you I'm this close to
I'm mad at him cause I thought I would
have a white slave but I thought
I thought it was Vengeance name
gonna have me a white family old big old
fat white girl go warm my bed up get
upstairs Susan
warm my bed up feed my baby with your
giant white titties and I'm gonna go
outside and stare your husband in the
face and decide whether I'm gonna sell
him or not
[Applause]
Phillip
[Applause]
that's uncomfortable ain't it that's
something that's uncomfortable I
apologize
[Applause]